joining us now is the founder of one of
the country's biggest pub chains
hugh osmond thank you very much for
being with us mr osmond
and we're just talking there about boris
johnson's promise to level up the
country at the election are you worried
that
because of the economic hits of covid
and because of the tier system
that england is going to be moving into
this week that we may actually see a
leveling down
yes good morning i mean i'd say exactly
that i mean i think
sometimes that these politicians live in
another
world you know they live in something of
an ivory tower
and if they would get out and about if
boris would actually get out and about
and meet
the people who have lost and are losing
their livelihoods
their businesses uh the way to support
their families
because of these restrictions you know
people in hospitality
are seeing their businesses shut down
with people put out of work
all across the country and he needs to
meet some of those people and see how
his measures are destroying those lives
and balance that against the very
limited good that
he is seeing some of these businesses
that will unfortunately fail if the
restrictions continue
they will not reopen you know possibly
ever
and all this talk of leveling up and
leveling down
if he destroys an industry or the
hospitality industry and the retail
industry
which are the biggest employers of young
people
the biggest offerers of entry-level jobs
to people who don't have great
qualifications
if he destroys all those jobs and all
those businesses
he will not achieve his leveling up
there will be extensive misery there
will be
more health problems more suicides more
deaths
and a much worse economy than he could
ever imagine he needs to get out and
meet some of the people
um whose lives he's destroying wow um
pretty strong stuff there clearly
something you feel passionately about
and
it's worth kind of reflecting on your
background you know you kind of founded
punch taverns one of the biggest pub
chains
involved in setting up of pizza express
as well
i know how hard it is to quantify these
things but you know how many businesses
could be at risk hit well obviously it
does depend on what happens next
uh we appear to have had um thanks to
perhaps
you know some good work by uh sir by
certain mps for which
uh you know we in the industry are very
grateful we appear to have had a bit of
a rowing back from
the idea of these restrictions all the
way through
till easter but if they were to go that
long
obviously depending somewhat on other
forms of government support
if they were to go on that long you
would be looking at millions of job
losses just in hospitality
let alone retail where of course we've
seen arcadia fail
and you know i i would just make the
point i know others have made it
but in in terms of um the risk
you know the average age of people we
employees in in their early 20s and most
of our customers
and that's also true of retail
and since the epidemic if that's what it
is since
it started the total number of healthy
people
under 40 who've actually sadly died of
the disease
has been just 46. you know that's 46
46 not 46 million 46 people out of 55
million
under 40 who were healthy have died of
this and we need to get it in proportion
because he is destroying
the lives of many people who are in
their 20s
when they have absolutely zero risk
of this disease you know my son's friend
from university was saying
yesterday that at their university 1300
students have
tested positive not a single one has
even been hospital
uh i don't even know if any of them been
see the doctor so you're destroying the
lives of a generation that actually
doesn't suffer from the disease and they
need to balance
that terrible destruction with the
possible good they are saying and they
need to think of other measures that
might save more lives
and and create less destruction you
could be seeing you know a million or
two million
unemployed just from retail and
hospitality
um depending on what happens next
what the government would argue is that
the best way to
help the economy is to suppress the
virus because it means that if we
get a grip on it then we can get back to
normal
more quickly and they would argue that
yes although of course age is a big
factor in how ill people get
they're also worried about young
people's ability to spread the virus as
well
i mean they do need to balance their
health risks as well don't they
well you know they produce there's a
very large study as you probably know so
if you know by the nhs which is 12 and a
half million
adults and there is actually absolutely
no
evidence uh that even in families where
there are members over 65
the the children being at school and
what have you increased the risk to
those adults in fact there's
some evidence that somehow perhaps by
spread
by the immunity from um other viruses
which we now know exists you know such
as uh common colds not immunity but
resistance
that in fact parents of children who go
to school
and perhaps have had these costs of
colds have a slightly lower risk
and this is in a study of 12 and a half
million adults
so i think this whole idea that you can
suppress it in
society and that makes people safer you
know a long study in the lancet
also one in the british medical journal
the two most reputable journals
in the uk both say that lockdowns and
measures do not save lives
they may possibly postpone the event in
which case perhaps the var
the vaccine is helpful but the reality
is it would have always been
far easier to protect the elderly
i mean the only thing probably we knew
in january about this disease from
the outbreak in china you know if we
knew just one single thing
we knew that it was very very dangerous
for the very old and the very ill now if
i'd known that
the single thing i would have done would
have been to protect care homes and
people in geriatric wards
and yet as we heard from a member of
sage the other day they actually didn't
even think about it
it is not a measure in the imperial
model in the imperial model that models
for the different
non-pharmaceutical inventions as they
politely call
idiotic measures like lockdowns there is
not even an intervention that involves
protecting care homes
and you heard this chat this professor
last week saying well we just didn't
think about
it we didn't ask whether they were being
protected we assumed it
that could have saved half the lives
that had been lost
in that one measure instead they locked
down the entire country
for no reason okay i'm pretty clear that
you've got some strong views on the
impact
of lockdown and you've previously
donated to the conservative party would
you say that the conservatives are still
friends of business and
not at the moment look i i think the the
treasury
is responding in whatever way it can
and actually doing a pretty good job in
supporting jobs
but it does rely on this magic money
tree i mean when you say 400 billion
you know that is many times the annual
budget of the nhs you know we could have
spent that on improving the nhs and
saving generations of the future so i
think overall
uh in the health department they're
completely ignorant of how business
works and
even what the other effects on health
are of this virus
in the treasury they are giving what
support they can i mean i'd like to say
that
you know on a more positive note and
having um
complained about government i mean we
intend to come out of this crisis
to invest you know i i still plan to
open
a new restaurant on december the 9th so
very shortly we've been working on it
all through lockdown
a new copper club in in cobham we raised
25 million for our restaurants we've
raised 300 million dollars for another
uh vehicle i intend as soon as these
ridiculous measures come to an end
i do intend to invest and start
employing people
and reopen the high street and get
things going again so i'm not and i'm
sure that
the government will try to support that
they just need to focus on the damage
they're doing in the meantime
and and get out of the way you know use
their testing program to protect the
vulnerable
rather than test all these students let
the rest of us get on with it so we can
stop
a a crisis that could turn into a three
four
five year um economic event
now we they need to let us invest so we
can get on with stopping that get on
with the recovery
definitely good to see that uh you're
still planning to invest i'm sure you
have floods of applicants for those jobs
when they are advertised and just
quickly because we are
running out of time um the chief
executive of uk hospitality said
in today's sunday times that if the tier
system lasts till easter
we'll be walking through the smoldering
ruins of an industry that was the third
largest in the uk are you also worried
that this
sector so important to the uk economy
may never actually recover from this
well never's a long time sophie um but i
think
the every day that goes by
uh more owner operator and big
businesses
go out of business thanks to these
measures so
yes i think many people are
many people are closing their doors
every day now um
and just to be clear you know under tier
two let alone tier three
most hospitality businesses are not
viable
and for many people that is their entire
livelihood
so yes if this were to go on in through
to
easter i i think a very huge fraction of
the industry
would close many individual owner
operators many people who work in those
businesses would lose their jobs
and it would take years to recover years
to recover you know we we would
you know we will be trying to recover
and reopen the high street but it will
take years if they carry on with these
measures
um i just think they need to get out
there and see the actual people
and they will see that this is not you
know just voices for the hospitality
industry
making scary statements like they tend
to do with with charts and predictive
models
this is not a model you know this is not
a model that looks to
see into the future like some fortune
teller or some
oracle or the prophets in the bible like
they use their mob
models this is stuff that's actually
happening now people are losing their
jobs
now you know they are going out of
business now they are losing the way to
support their families now
you know it's already happening it's not
something that will happen it is
happening
right now okay um strong words there
thank you
very much for coming on the program and
talking a little bit about the impact on
the hospitality
industry thank you thanks thank you very
much